The three engines of growth are ways
to think about customer acquisition.
The first one is the sticky
engine of growth,
where you're going to focus on bringing
your customers back month after month.
You really want them to stick with you.
You're really focusing here on
keeping customers with you,
rather than acquiring new customers.
So, this is the right
engine to focus on,
if your focused on retaining
customers for the long term.
The second engine of growth
is the viral engine.
This is usually heaven for
entrepreneurs,
where they get to the point where their
customers are bringing in new customers.
And their user base is just
growing virally and organically.
Now I wouldn't rely on this one, because
it's really hard to actually get here.
Your product is going to
have to be incredible, and
really fit your target market perfectly,
otherwise it doesn't really work.
So once you have a really awesome
product, growth can be self sustaining,
but it doesn't necessarily
happen to everyone.
And the third engine of growth
is the paid engine of growth.
Most start ups have to be
familiar with this one.
And most advertising channels
fall into this engine.
Now as long as you're making
a profit on each customer,
you can keep operating this engine.
Your profit will allow you to invest
more and more into advertising and
help you sustain your growth.
Now big companies will focus on more
than one or even all of these engines.
However, as a startup, we recommend
that you focus on only one at a time.
In this lesson in particular we'll
be focusing on the paid engine for
customer acquisition.
If you're interested in learning more,
we highly recommend checking
out the book The Lean Startup.
It describes these three engines as
part of a whole lean startup approach,
that helps entrepreneurs build
fast growing companies, and
encourages them to build, measure and
learn on an ongoing basis.
Check out the link to the book
in the instructor notes.
Okay, so let's dive into
this paid engine of growth.